كل حال من الاردن سالنا عدد من مشجعي كره
القدم ومشجعي ميسي بالاخص كثار
سالناهم انه هل يجب الضغط على ليونيل ميسي
للفوز بكاس العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لست من من يسددون الكره فيخطئون الهدف هذا
ما عرف به لاعب كره القدم ميسي وبعض تعليق
الامال عليه حمله معجبوه خساره الفريق
باكمله
[موسيقى]
يعني بطلب منه شد حيله بس انه الحمد لله
العرب كمان انه فاز امبارح ورفعوا راسنا
انا بحكي ده ميسي انه هاي مباراه كره قدم
يعني فيها الربحان وفيها الخصام بالعكس
كان ايذاءه كثير رائع كثير بس الحظ ما كان
معه ميسي هي الكل الدنيا بدهم برتغالي
نشوفها مع النهائي يعني حتى وانا بشجع
المانيا حاب اشوفها الفريقين لانه خلص
يعني اللجن الكره
والزمن كل اللي حوالي فا لا هو اللي
بنشوفهم
ضرب الشوط الثاني ما اعرفش يلعب بالسعوديه
لعبه كثير كويس الحارس والمدافعين لعبه
كيري كويس
[موسيقى]